all right party city is a one-stop
halloween shop their message this season
though
you boo you and make this halloween safe
and one to remember take a look
we're here with a few really special
trends and the products that party city
offers to make those possible
so let's get started um one of my
favorite trends this year is decorations
are going to be
bigger than ever so whether people are
choosing to decorate their porches or
their lawns
lots of people are doing tablescapes
inside the home or going full out for
the kids and decorating the living room
the party city offers not only kits for
all of those locations so
porch decorating kits lawn decorating
kits with
great products like our graveyard that
you can set up in your yard
so parents that are really in a time
crunch and are looking to pick up those
kits and make it really easy
can run to a las vegas area location
or check out partycity.com not only for
the kits themselves but also for how-to
inspiration and diys to pull it all
together we all need some projects we
all need
you know to keep it here so what can we
do ahead
what are your ideas especially the kids
yeah blue baskets
so booing is when you take either a
treat bag you can use
a basket a bag itself and you fill it
with
all kinds of little goodies and this is
something that's really easy to get the
kids involved in
so we like to use party favors like
little games
you can use candy try and make sure that
it's nice and wrapped for the kids
and then you can grab anything from
sunglasses
maybe you throw in some chocolates for
the adults throw them in a little bag
and then you put a handwritten note on
it or you can use one of the printables
available at partycity.com
and just right you've been booed maybe
you have the kids write a cute little
halloween message
you drop it off on a neighbor's doorstep
and then they can either
keep it anonymous and you guys can all
guess who the ghost is around the
neighborhood and
keep the whole neighborhood in the
holiday spirit with that that's great
right or you can take the note itself
and put it in your window so that the
neighbors know okay this neighbor has
been booed
and their job has been to pass along the
tradition to the next house for a loved
one
and pretty soon the whole neighborhood
is involved it offers a great contact
free way
to still spread some of that halloween
spirit i love that it brings everybody
together
another one of our great safe options we
have our halloween face masks this year
what i love about these is you can wear
them and then you can also
do makeup around them so we have great
makeup kits
and different diy we have great little
gemstones and things that you can pair
with your mask
we have now launched a las vegas mobile
tour
it is halloween themed so it's this
really festive truck with
instagramable um photo booths they're
doing daily coupon giveaways
we have all kinds of fun activities for
the kids and of course we have
merchandise and some of our
most popular costumes we have a few
upcoming stops
so this saturday on october 24th we will
be at the
las vegas grand prix on north rainbow
and we'll be there from 6 to 9 p.m so be
sure to stop by
and then next week we will be at the
drive-thru haunted western at the
whitney ranch recreation center
we'd love for people to stop by